We're on problem 20.
Of the 5 coordinates associated
with points A, B,
C, D and E on the number line
above, which has the greatest
absolute value?
OK.
Let me just draw the number
line that they drew.
And they say from 0 to 1.
0, 1, 2.
And then they say minus
1, minus 2.
And then they say these are
choices A, B, C, D, and E.
Of the 5 coordinates associated
with the points A,
B, C, D, and E on the number
line above, which has the
greatest absolute value?
So you can view absolute value
as the distance from zero So
the greatest distance from
zero is going to
happen in two places.
It's going to happen
here at A.
It's also going to
happen here at E.
Can you have more than
one right answer?
Because both of those
are choices.
Let's see.
Indicate the best of the
answer choices given.
I'm looking up the thing.
Is it possible to have more
than one right answer?
Because this doesn't seem quite
right that I can have
two possible answers
for this one.
The answer is A.
The coordinate A is the
farthest from zero.
This has the greatest
absolute value.
I disagree with that.
It could be choice E as well.
The absolute value of the
number x is the distance
between x and 0 on
the number line.
The coordinate of point A is the
farthest from 0, and thus
has the greatest
absolute value.
That's false.
I mean, that's true, but
E is just as far.
I don't know, I think
they made a mistake.
I think this could be choices
A or E, because the absolute
value of either of those is 2.
I think they made a mistake.
And they say the choice is A,
which I agree with, but it
could just as easily
be choice E.
So I don't know.
Write a letter to GMAT.
I mean, this seems pretty
straightforward.
Of the 5 coordinates associated
with choices A, B,
C, D, and E on the number line,
which has the greatest
absolute value?
The absolute value of
this point is 2.
They're equal.
Anyway.
Next problem.
I think it should be A or E.
It's surprising that they would
let a question like that
get through their screen.
Or at least they should
get rid of choice E.
If x and y are prime numbers,
which of the following cannot
be the sum of x and y?
x plus y cannot equal what?
So statement 1: 5.
Well, I can immediately say
2 plus 3 is equal to 5.
So that doesn't work.
Cannot equal, so B.
9, I could do 2 plus
7 is equal to 9.
This was A.
This is B.
Let's see what C is.
So it's not B.
C is 13.
So let me think.
What could it be?
11 plus 2 is equal to 13,
so it's not choice C.
D.
16.
The sum.
So let me see, 16.
9 and 7.
No.
11 and 5.
11 plus 5 is equal to 16.
So without even looking at E,
it's probably going to be E.
E , 23.
Let me see if I can come up with
two prime numbers that
add up to 23.
19 and 4.
No.
Let's see.
2 and 21.
No.
First of all, we found examples
for all of these, so
if you don't want to waste time
on the GMAT, you should
already have chosen E and moved
on by this point, but we
could just look through a bunch
of prime numbers and
think if they can add up to 23,
but I can't think of any
right at the moment.
And I feel pretty good that E
is the answer, because I was
able to find prime numbers that
added up to all of the
other four choices.
Next question.
22.
I'll switch colors just
to ease the monotony.
If each of the following
fractions were written as a
repeating decimal, which would
have the longest sequence of
different digits?
Are they going to sit here and
make us-- so let me write all
the choices down.
Maybe we can do some
cancellation from the get-go.
2/11.
B is 1/3.
And we already know
that that's just
going to be 0.33 repeating.
Longest sequence of
different digits.
So it's not going to be choice
B because choice B doesn't
have different digits.
It just keeps being a 3, so it's
not going to be choice B,
so we don't have to
worry about that.
Choice C.
41/99.
Choice D is 2/3.
We know that that's 0.666.
It just keeps going.
So it's not going to be that.
It's the same digit that
just keeps repeating.
And choice E is 23
divided by 37.
So 2 divided by 11 repeats.
Let's just try it, though.
11 goes into 2.000 one time.
1 times 11 is 11.
You get a 90.
11 goes into 90 eight times.
88.
It's 20.
I already see the pattern.
11 goes into 20 two times.
Sorry, it goes into
20 one time.
1 times 11 is 11.
Then you get a 90.
It goes into it eight times,
so it's just 0.181818.
It's just going to keep
repeating 0.18.
So that's 2/11.
41/99.
Let me do it in a different
color just so I
don't get too messy.
99 goes into 41.0000.
So 99 goes into 410
four times.
4 times 99 is what?
396.
4 times 9 is 6.
3.
4 times 9 is 36.
Yep, 396.
This is equal to 140.
99 goes into 140 one time.
1 times 99 is 99.
This becomes 41.
Already started repeating,
right?
99 goes into 410.
That's just like that.
So it's going to be 0.41
repeating over and over again
because we got the same
number again.
We're going 99 into
41 four times.
We're going to get
396 and it's just
going to keep happening.
Then we're going to get 396.
And then we're going
to get 140 again.
It's 41, 41.
So it's 41 repeating.
So if I had to guess, it's
already going to be choice E,
without having to do any work
because these just have the
same numbers repeating
from the get-go.
Choices A and C have the
same two numbers
repeating from the get-go.
So I'm guessing that this
one has a lot more.
So if you just wanted to worry
about time, you could just
pick E and move on.
But let's do it just to
prove to ourselves.
So 37 goes into 23.
I don't remember when I took
the GMAT having to do this
much decimal division or
decimal multiplication.
So 37 goes into 230.
I don't know.
Does it go into it six times?
No, probably five times.
5 times 7 is 35.
5 times 3 is 15, so
it's 18, plus 3.
OK.
30.
85.
Actually, this would have
gone six times.
Let me change that to 6.
Let me to it in a
different color.
I don't want to make
it too messy.
6 times 7 is 42.
6 times 3 is 18, plus 4 is 22.
80.
37 goes into 80 two times.
2 times 37 is what?
74, right?
60 plus 14.
74.
You get a 60.
30 is going to go into 60.
So already we haven't even
started repeating and we're
already three digits into it.
So this is going to have
the longest sequence
of different digits.
We don't have to keep going.
We've answered our question.
The choice is definitely E.
Next question.
They've drawn something there.
In the figure above the
coordinates of point V are--
well, this is just kind
of a reading the
graph type of problem.
I'm just going to draw this 4th
quadrant just so that I
can show you how I
think about it.
OK, so let me just count: one,
two, three, four, five; one,
two, three, four, five.
They tell us that each of those
slashes are 1, because
they do it in a couple
of places.
They go one, two, three, four,
five, and then they say this
is negative 5.
So that's information that
you actually need.
You have to know that each
of those slashes
are definitely 1.
But then on this, they
go one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
So they go one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, so
this is point 7.
And you have to just count
it on your paper.
So this is one, two,
three, four, five.
And this is point one, two,
This is minus 5.
And this is where V is.
So they're just testing
to see if you know
how to graph a point.
So this is x is 7.
And y is minus 5.
So it's 7 minus 5.
And actually, that's
interesting.
You don't even have to count the
points, because you say,
you know what?
This is in the 4th quadrant.
x is positive.
y is negative.
And if you look at all the
choices, there's only one
choice where x is positive
and y is negative, and
that's choice E.
So you really didn't even have
to count it, although I think
this wouldn't have taken much
time to count it, so that's
not like a huge shortcut.
Anyway, see you in
the next video.